[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo sur ce plateau monjoin
trois invités fabienne keller bonjour au
député élu en mai dernier sur la liste
de la majorité présidentielle fait
partie du groupe pro new europe
renouveler l'europe a le groupe du
parlement européen où siègent les
députés français de renaissance la liste
soutenue par la république en marche
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
manuel bompard bonjour vous êtes député
européen du groupe de la gauche unitaire
européenne ici au parlement européen
également élu en mai dernier un élu sous
les couleurs de la france
insoumise merci d'être venus en ce1
karima delli bonjour vous êtes député
européen élu sur la liste europe
écologie les verts membres du groupe des
verts ici au parlement européen vous
n'êtes pas une novice si je ne m'abuse
vous avez vous attaquer si je ne m'abuse
votre troisième mandat merci d'être venu
alors l'actualité en amour immigration
les européens discutent de la
répartition automatique des migrants
secourues en méditerranée ont même
trouvé un accord au même moment à le
thème de l'immigration fait sa rentrée
en france on regarde et on réagit juste
après
[Musique]
ces sauvetages en mer méditerranée d'un
migrants venus tenter leur chance dans
l'eldorado européen les pays côtiers ne
veulent plus les assumer seule le
règlement de dublin confie le traitement
des demandes d'asile au pays d'arrivée
une règle injuste parce qu'elle fait
reposer pour de simples raisons
géographiques le fardeau de l'accueil
sur l'italie la grèce l'espagne ou malte
principale porte d'entrée des migrants
réunis à malte la semaine dernière les
ministres de l'intérieur des cinq pays
de l'union se sont mises d'accord sur un
nouveau mécanisme de répartition plus
solidaire
nous avons obtenu un accord sur un
document commun qui sera présenté au
conseil des ministres de l'intérieur
le 8 octobre face la france et
l'allemagne accepterait d'accueillir
chacune 25 % des migrants secourues
tandis que l'italie en recevraient 10%
seuls les pays volontaires intègreront
le nouveau système qui ne concernera que
les migrants arrivant par la mer
je pense que ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui est très important parce que
c'est le premier acte d'un accord
une première étape concrète pour une
action commune dans l' approche
européenne et européens et j'ai trouvé
une atmosphère très positive parce que
la politique migratoire est une
politique qui doit être élaboré avec les
autres pays c est mal à rester des je
dois dire que nous avons toujours dit
ces dernières années que celui ou celle
qui arrive à malte ou en italie arrive
en europe
et voilà le thème de l'immigration qui
fait sa rentrée en europe en france
l'exécutif veut réformer sa politique
migratoire un débat sur le sujet aura
lieu au parlement
trop de contre-vérités jeudi déjà dix
circulent au sujet de l'immigration
parfois des fantasmes même il doit aussi
nous permettre le cas échéant et si cela
était jugé nécessaire au cours du débat
d'apporter de nouvelles réponses
d'apporter des ajustements et pourquoi
pas des mesures législatives
parmi les pistes envisagées intégré plus
rapidement les réfugiés mais aussi
limiter l'attractivité de la france avec
des allocations diminuent et paris
aimerait aussi transférer les migrants
arrivés en france vers les pays
européens où ils ont été enregistrées en
premier enfin paris veut expulser plus
facilement les migrants économiques
selon l'eurobaromètre l'immigration est
le sujet numéro un dans la liste des
préoccupations chez les citoyens
européens
[Musique]
alors sur le volet européen d'abord cet
accord sur la répartition des migrants
secourues en mer méditerranée un bon
accord fabienne keller a c'est une
démarche très pragmatique
ces cinq états membres qui se mettent
d'accord pour avancer et gérer les
migrants qui arrivent par cette route de
la méditerranée enfin que c'est une
manière très très positive d'avancer et
de montrer aux autres états membres qui
sont pas encore prêts à faire le pas que
c'est possible de gérer un accueil
humaniste humanitaire en respectant les
personnes répartition automatique avec
la france l'allemagne le portugal
luxembourg malte qui s'engageraient
automatiquement un bon accord en tout
cas il faut mettre un terme à ce système
absurde qui est que ce sont les pays sur
lequel les personnes mettent la première
fois le pied sur le sol européen qui
doivent gérer les demandes d'asile
italie la grèce c'est un système qui
n'est pas tenable vous demander à ces
pays là d'assumer seul la difficulté que
ça peut poser dans certaines situations
donc c'est une bonne chose de le
remettre en cause maintenant est-ce que
ça doit passer par des quotas ou des
répartitions je suis un peu dubitatif
circonspect migrants car ils sont pas
des marchandises qu'on va trier c'est
des situations humaines je crois plutôt
qu'il faut mettre un terme aux accords
de dublin et permettre aux gens de faire
les demandes d'asile dans le pays de
leur choix
cette réaction sur cet accord karim
madani je crois surtout c'est qu'on n'a
pas tiré les leçons de voeux 2014
on avait une europe avec des états
égoïste et l'inaction de l'europe
puisque au plus haut de la crise rien
n'avait été fait la deuxième chose qu'on
est en droit de réclamer nous
parlementaires c'est que l'europe comme
la france doit être à la hauteur du défi
de la solidarité et de l'hospitalité je
rappelle on n'a pas une crise des
migrants ou de réfugiés on a une crise
de l'accueil est bon par l'adie la
question des réfugiés a été
instrumentalisée notamment en italie
pour justement faire monter les partis
d'extrême droite moi je crois que c'est
très dangereux
et qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin aujourd'hui
c'est véritablement d'un dispositif
complet droit d'asile doit être
appliquée c'est un droit ces enfants ces
femmes et ces hommes ont des droits
donc le droit d'asile doit être
appliquée
la deuxième chose je crois que tous les
dirigeants européens devraient avoir
honte puisque la méditerranée quand même
le plus grand cimetière à ciel ouvert et
personnes s'est dit il faut qu'on
s'organise avec vraiment une flotte
européenne qui soit au niveau pour
l'instant on l'a toujours pas et 3 c'est
la question de l'accueil et l'accueil je
veux vous le dire moi j'ai visité des
centres notamment de réfugiés on n'est
vraiment pas à la hauteur
donc maintenant il faut absolument qu'on
re découvre et qu'on met en avant ses
valeurs et faire en sorte que oui le
système de dublin
mais la convention de dublin même le
parlement l'a rappelé deux fois nous
l'avons casser la balle est haut dans le
camp maintenant des états membres a bien
grandi c'est en cours ça commence à
bouger alors je partage la révolte la
colère de karima delli les situations
des camps de réfugiés sont inadmissibles
la vie des publinets dont qui rentrent
par exemple en italie et qui se
déplacent mais dans une interdiction
mais qu'on vérifie pas vraiment pour
déposer leur demande d'asile dans un
autre état membre pour avoir plus de
chance on comprend leur démarche
c'est inadmissible c'est pas une belle
manière de traiter je veux dire qu'il y
a des points qui avancent par exemple
dans les auditions en ce moment des
commissaires le parlement européen nous
les commissions nous demandons ce qu'il
va en est de ce paquet asile qui a été
adoptée par le parlement européen dans
une vision plus ouverte un plus
responsable mais qui aujourd'hui bloquée
au conseil c'est à dire chez chez les
chefs d'état notamment par la pologne
hier jusqu'à hier par l'italie par la
hongrie qui ne souhaitent pas avoir un
dispositif plus intégrée de l'asie sur
la question du sauvetage en mer
simplement c'est important en commission
budget nous avons décidé d'affecter une
partie des moyens pour le rescue à des
navires opérés soit par l'union
européenne en direct soit par des ong
soit par des états membres les
gouvernements je partage le fait qu' on
n'est pas du tout au bout mais il me
semble que le parlement européen est
prêt mais également les institutions
essaye vraiment d'avancé sur des
solutions pragmatiques parce que
je partage l'idée que cette question de
l'immigration qui aujourd'hui est gérée
avec des règles pas vraiment appliquée
c'est inadmissible
et cela fait le lit du populisme mais le
parlement européen a fait son travail
sauf que les chefs d'état ont pris des
décisions qui sont indignes lorsqu'on
dit que c'est la turquie qui va sous
traiter les réfugiés alors que c'est à
nous de prendre en charge l'accueil de
ces gens ont l'art a donné 6 milliards
d'euros à la turquie pour gérer nos
propres réfugiés quel scandale
deuxième chose on devrait tous être
révolté notamment sur certains pays
comme le nôtre sur le délit de
solidarité
mais ça va pas ou quoi on est dans un
moment où la fraternité la solidarité
doivent être des priorités et nous on
sanctionne des gens qui aiderait juste
des enfants des femmes et des hommes au
détriment de leur vie ils sont pas venus
ici juste comme certains voudraient
faire croire
profitez de quoi que ce soit non c'est
au détriment de leur vie et ensuite je
rappelle une chose il n'ya aucune
prospective sur ces questions
d'immigration le fait de ne pas lier la
question du réchauffement climatique
avec demain les réfugiés climatiques
c'est une catastrophe
j'aimerais que les responsables et les
chefs d'état lisent le rapport du giec
qui dit d'ici dix à vingt ans si nous ne
faisons rien
ces 280 millions de réfugiés climatiques
il va falloir gérer et ben c'est en
train de s'organiser ça donc il n'ya
qu'une réponse à ça c'est de remettre un
peu d'humain de solidarité mais surtout
d'hospitalité pour que les gens qui sont
en france comme n'importe quel pays
européens puissent être accueillis
dignement vous en parliez fabienne
keller allait les pays de l'est ne
veulent toujours pas prendre leur parle
ça pose problème est-ce qu'il faut plus
de sanctions à faire jouer les fonds
structurels mettre en parallèle je crois
pas qu'il faille sanctionné en utilisant
l'outil des fonds structurels parce que
c'est faire payer aux populations de ces
pays n'y sont pour rien les actes de
leurs dirigeants
donc je crois pas que ça soit une bonne
solution par contre s'il est vrai que
vous pouvez pas avoir à la fois une
pression d'un certain nombre de détails
notamment des pays de l'est par exemple
à la baisse de notre système social au
refus des politiques de solidarité
internationale au refus de la prise en
charge de l'impératif écologique et
climatique
et dire nous on accepte ça et on est
obligé de faire des compromis avec eux
mais que par contre sur la question de
l'accueil et de l'immigration
là on sera obligé d'accepter leurs
règles ça c'est pas possible donc
nécessairement il doit y avoir quand
même des systèmes d'oppression et de
rapports de force parce que sinon c'est
pas possible que au sein de l'union
européenne y est que quelques pays qui
fasse les efforts de solidarité qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient nécessaires je veux
juste dire que je partage
deux choses qu'on dit karima delli la
première c'est que malheureusement le
gouvernement français n'est pas en
mesure aujourd'hui de donner des leçons
au reste de l'europe parce qu'on parlait
de la situation dans les centres de
rétention c'est quand même la loi asile
et immigration voté par emmanuel macron
qu'à prolonger la durée des 90 jours et
la deuxième chose c'est que on peut pas
sortir la question de l'immigration des
grands sujets que sont devant nous
sociaux écologiques commerciaux que si à
de l'immigration c'est parce qu'il ya
des situations de misère économique
qu'il ya des situations de guerre que ya
le problème du climat et des réfugiés
climatiques etc si on veut attaquer de
manière globale la question de
l'immigration
on doit répondre aussi à ces questions
là on finir justement est ce que dans le
budget européen doit consacrer plus de
fonds et l'aide au développement
alors évidemment même si l'europe est le
premier financeur aujourd'hui de l'aide
au développement
l'enjeu majeur il est dans les pays du
sud
on parle des migrations vers l'europe
mais il faut avoir conscience que les
migrations intra africaines notamment de
l'ouest vers l'est à travers la zone
sahélienne sont absolument considérable
et met en grande fragilité
un des peuples qui déjà sont très
pauvres départ est encore fragilisé des
structures et pas par ses mouvements il
fuit soit la guerre soit d
appauvrissement des terres qui les
conduisent à cette errance
donc oui pour les nord-sud et vous
clairement une priorité marqué c'est un
engagement fort
le renew europe de la majorité
présidentielle en france donner beaucoup
plus de poids à la priorité climatique
la priorité écologique parce qu'on le
sait c'est la double peine sont des pays
peu émetteur de gaz à effet de serre qui
sont les premiers pénalisés par le
réchauffement climatique
mais pour revenir à votre question tout
à l'heure je voudrais dire sur la
question de l'immigration
il faut essayer de sortir de l'idée
logis parce que pour l'instant ce sont
les populistes qui gagne et être plutôt
dans la solidarité dans la coopération
comme ça a été fait à malte
il ya quelques jours et avancer avec les
états membres qui le veulent bien et je
suis convaincu qu'il ya une grande
majorité des états membres qui sont
prêts à avancer et pour pouvoir
entraîner le moment venu au conseil
une décision dont je rappelle qu'elle
peut être prise à majorité qualifiée et
donc à un moment donné si les peuples
sont prêts parce qu'une solution
équilibrée raisonnable sur cette
question de l'immigration est construite
et bien en faire une règle européenne
daniel keller justement vous étiez avec
le président la république à strasbourg
emmanuel macron a choisi le cadre de
l'assemblée du conseil de l'europe à
strasbourg pour assister sur la
nécessité de réformer le droit d'asile à
et l'a prévenu mardi dans son discours
que ce droit pouvait disparaître si rien
n'était fait on écoute on réagit juste
après
mais si nous ne sommes pas capables de
répondre efficacement aux défis
migratoires si nous n'avons pas le
courage de regarder en face la demande
de maîtrise exprimé par tous nos
concitoyens
si nous n'avons pas la lucidité de voir
que dans de si nombreux cas la demande
d'asile vient de pays profondément sur
qui sont pour certains en train de
vouloir ouvrir des négociations avec
l'union européenne ou avec lesquelles
nous avons la liberté de circulation
complète et que aujourd'hui la demande
d'asile est l'objet de manière évidente
d'un contournement si ce n'était un
détournement
nous ne serions pas lucide avec nous
mêmes avec notre droit avec les
principes de ce droit et avec ce que
notre peuple nous dit si nous laissons
le droit d'asile devenir objet de
détournement de frat de trafic
il disparaîtra manuellement pas une
réaction à ce discours d' emmanuel
macron il faut être plus dur avec
l'immigration économique pour protéger
le droit d'asile
non je comprends pas comment il peut
faire le lien entre les deux en réalité
le droit d'asile c'est un engagement que
nous avons qui je pense est dans les
valeurs qui sont les nôtres et bien
évidemment il faut le respecter
après la question du contrôle des flux
migratoires
encore une fois poste d autres questions
sur comment effectivement ont réduit ces
flux mais ont réduit ces flux en faisant
en sorte que les gens n'aient plus
besoin de partir pas en espérant ce qui
me paraît il parle de lucidité tout à
fait illusoire de penser qu'on va
arriver à faire en sorte que des gens
qui sont prêts à partager traverser la
mer méditerranée c'est à dire le plus
grand fossé du monde
on arrive à les arrêter autrement donc
la question ne peut pas être posée dans
ces termes là ça me paraît pas
raisonnable
si on veut parler de ces questions là de
manière raisonnablement on garantit le
droit d'asile
premièrement et deuxièmement si on veut
s'attaquer aux flux migratoires on agit
sur les causes des migrations et quand
les gens arrivent sur le territoire et
ben on les accueille dignement parce que
c'est notre devoir de solidarité et
d'humanité
karima delli faut réformer le droit
d'asile la france est vraiment trop part
active
la france n'est pas trop attractif je
pense que la france mérite de regarder
se sont passées lorsqu'il y avait valéry
giscard d'estaing
il a fait une chose extraordinaire il a
reçu
bras ouverts deux cent mille boat people
200000 boat people et nous on n'est pas
capable aujourd'hui alors que la france
est la sixième puissance mondiale
d'accueillir des gens qui viennent mais
au détriment je dis et je le répète au
détriment de leur vie je ne trouve que
c'est pas acceptable
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut
renforcer notre droit d'accueil nous
avons tous les dispositifs pour bien
faire en france la france doit être à
nouveau fiers de ces valeurs et je
n'aime pas qu'on instrumentalise
justement le débat sur l'immigration
vous savez quand vous regardez tous les
sondages la priorité des français comme
des européens c'est pas l'immigration
c'est la question du réchauffement
climatique
et pourquoi ça arrive maintenant ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est quand on regarde la france
par rapport aux autres pays européens
nous ne n'accueillons absolument qu'une
goutte d'eau
regardez l'allemagne regarder la
belgique regardez les les pays
limitrophes c'est incroyable la france
n'est pas à la hauteur
la troisième chose qui est vraiment pour
moi évidente bien sûr que le droit
d'asile il faut et moi je le dis hein il
faut que mettre fin aux accords de
dublin
mais il faut que la politique d'accueil
soient renforcés au niveau budgétaire
parce que ce n'est pas au niveau et donc
là il va falloir que l'europe s'engage
sur une véritable un véritable
investissement la deuxième chose c'est
que tout ça c'est beau fait
mais quel est le calendrier dites-nous
alors que déjà la commission européenne
et moi je le dis je suis assez fâché on
a le titre d'un commissaire qui ce qui
se dit protection de la vie des citoyens
européens et c'est lui qui serait en
charge notamment des questions
d'immigration comme si les régimes voilà
était une une une un problème pour la
vie des citoyens européens c'est pas ça
l'europe et donc moi j'invite madame von
der leyen je le redis 1 et je pense que
perth tout le monde sur ce plateau le
partage on ne peut pas accepter ce titre
de portefeuille de commissaire j'espère
qu'elle l'entend et que l'élection du
mode de vie est belle mais voilà des
propos qui sont des mêmes propos que
l'extrême droite
nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter la
deuxième chose c'est d'être ambitieux
ambitieux ça veut dire faire de la
prospective avant un calendrier
un budget et faire en sorte que demain
on n'est pas honte de notre passé parce
qu'on n'aurait rien fait bleu clair je
le disais à vous étiez aux côtés du
président la république à strasbourg le
droit d'asile est victime d'un
détournement de trafic comme le dit le
chef de temps alors il y a
la situation de l'asile est complexe
puisque il y à des personnes qui migrent
pour différentes raisons pour le
regroupement familial s'est autorisé
s'est organisé pour le travail
et puis il ya les deux mineurs d'asile
protégés par la convention des droits de
l'homme et parce qu'ils sont poursuivis
dans leur pays d'origine ils subissent
des guerres ou en raison de leur
parcours de leur engagement politique de
leur vie personnelle
ils sont poursuivis donc effectivement
les pays principaux d'origine sont
l'albanie et la géorgie aujourd'hui
s'agissant des demandes d'asile en
france et je pense que c'est ça cette
situation cette réalité à laquelle le
président de la république fait
référence alors que l'albanie par
exemple est un pays qui est en cours de
procédure avec l'union européenne dont
qui peut être considéré comme un état
dit sûr c'est qu'à priori des
ressortissants sauf situation
exceptionnelle non pas ne sont pas en
grand risque
mais il ya dans les textes de toute
façon une protection d'une personne qui
en raison de ses idées par exemple
seraient mises en difficulté en danger
personnel dans son pays donc je voudrais
saluer le courage du président quand il
se propose d'en débattre avec les
français et si karim a dit il ya plus de
migrants en allemagne c'est vrai mais
c'est dans le cadre d'une migration
organisée essentiellement suite à des
demandes des entreprises puisque
l'allemagne est en fort déficit
démographique donc parlons de ses
différentes formes de migration
parlons aussi de la mise en oeuvre des
règles d'asile je rappelle qu'elles sont
européennes mais elles sont parfois
différentes dans leur mise en oeuvre et
ça c'est particulièrement important
d'avoir une réalité de la mise en oeuvre
qui est identique
il se trouve que la france est
aujourd'hui perçu comme attractives par
les demandeurs d'asile c'est à dire que
nous avons beaucoup de migration
secondaire vers la france en particulier
en provenance d'italie puisque
avec salvini ministre de l'intérieur
jusqu'à récemment les migrants arrivant
en italie percevait que c'était plus
voilà plus propice de déposer leur
demande d'asile en france et sur un
contre très rapide sur l'accueil je
partage très rare millions nous devons
mettre beaucoup plus de moyens nous
mettons trois fois moins de moyens par
personne accueillie que les allemands le
gouvernement progressivement redresse
cette situation mais accueillir
apprendre la langue scolariser les
enfants évidemment ça fait cette
indispensable pour permettre un bon
accueil des personnes très connues
réfugiés donc au niveau français très
rapidement à le débat sensible sur
l'immigration doit se tenir lundi 7
octobre à l'assemblée nationale à
l'issue du grand débat national emmanuel
comme un accroc avait annoncé fin avril
un débat annuel au parlement sur la
politique migratoire il y avait urgence
de parler immigration selon vous très
rapidement mois on peut en débattre
mais si c'est pour l'instrumentaliser
justement à des fins politiciennes
ça ne marche pas je n'accepte pas qu'on
pourrait dire ya des bons réfugiés et il
ya des mauvais réfugiés qu'est ce que ça
veut dire on trie les gens ce n'est pas
tuer le boer en débatte de l'immigration
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'a pas attendu
ce débat pour le faire on en parle à peu
près tous les jours sur les plateaux de
télévision de la question migratoire
donc je pas sûr que la question se pose
en ces termes
maintenant si on veut poser parler de la
question d'immigration parlons de la
globalité ce que je disais tout à
l'heure la question climatique
la question des accords de libre échange
qui tue les économies du sud de la
question des guerres de notre place de
notre rapport à l'otan qui a une grande
question ici qu'est posée au parlement
européen par londres dans ce cas-là de
ces grandes caisses andy manuellement
par autre sujet d'actualité en france un
cas un écho européen c'est la pma pour
toutes à l'ouverture de la pma pour
toutes les femmes
approuvé par l'assemblée nationale à la
semaine dernière en première lecture et
dans le reste de l'europe c'est quoi la
règle il faut le savoir avant le vote de
l'article premier du projet de loi
bioéthique à la france faisait partie
des pays les plus restrictifs sur la
question on regarde on réagit juste
après
[Musique]
le parcours du combattant en france des
couples de femmes pour avoir des enfants
la députée laurens van den broeck mialon
le connaît elle l'a vécu en 2000 en
ayant recours à une pma en belgique puis
quatre ans plus tard lorsque sa compagne
portent leur seconde fille pour ma
première fille la plus grande donc
c'était fin à l'époque j'étais à lille
donc c'était relativement simple
techniquement en tout cas d'aller
jusqu'en belgique
j'ai juste subi on va dire comme toutes
les femmes lesbiennes
depuis que la procréation existant dans
les pays étrangers comme l'espagne la
belgique les pays bas finlande
l'obligation de chercher des solutions
pour pouvoir se procurer des traitements
mais c'est un peu démoralisant quand on
adore son pays et que bon on est un peu
obligé de le quitter un temps pour
bénéficier d'une pratique enfin très
simple une technique médicale très
simple qui est la procréation médicale
assistée à l'étranger et ont coincé
c'était un peu un banc privé un crève
coeur
alors quelle est la règle en europe
c'est un peu le chaud et le froid le
froid d'abord les pays restrictif la pma
limité aux couples hétérosexuels avec
diagnostic médical d'infertilité
il y à 13 pays qui dans cette définition
restreinte accepte la pma entre autres
la france la grèce l'allemagne la
hongrie la république tchèque et puis il
ya le show ce sont les pays qui
acceptent la pma pour les femmes
célibataires ou les couples homosexuels
il y a entre autres la belgique le
danemark le portugal la suède le royaume
uni ou l'espagne
cette clinique de madrid est l'un des
quelques 200 centres spécialisés dans la
procréation médicalement assistée en
espagne ici et depuis 2006 la pma est
autorisé pour toutes les femmes de 18
ans et plus seuls ou en couples
hétérosexuels ou homosexuels
plus de 5000 personnes franchissent
chaque année le seuil de cet hôpital
ici la législation autorise des
traitements interdit dans nombreux pays
lorsque ces femmes retournent dans leur
pays elles ne sont pas dans l'illégalité
puisque les ressortissants de l'union
européenne ont le droit de bénéficier de
soins médicaux dans tout autre pays de
l'union
quand on fait le tour de l'europe on
voit que la france fait partie des pays
les plus durs sur cette question mais
avec le vote en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale de la pma pour
toutes les choses ont changé
si on ouvre à tout le monde c'est à dire
aux couples de femmes et une femme
célibataire ou les femmes seules et que
la sécurité sociale prend en charge
l'essentiel des actes cliniques et
biologiques comme elle le fait
actuellement pour les couples
hétérosexuels et bien à ce moment là
vraiment la france sera un vrai modèle
d'un accès effectif à tout le monde
voilà c'est ça qui serait intéressant
l'idée c'est bien d'ouvrir à tout le
monde ça c'est vraiment un objectif ça
fait partie des promesses de campagne de
monsieur macro sans réduire la prise en
charge financière
et c'est pour ça que je tiens à ce qu'on
lit les deux volets parce qu'il me
semble par exemple que le modèle anglais
qui depuis 90 est ouvert à tout le monde
il est très théorique parce
qu'effectivement il ya que 25% des
procréation médicale assistée qui sont
prises en charge par le système de
sécurité sociale
contrairement mariage pour tous les
débats étaient houleux
aujourd'hui les discussions se déroulent
dans un climat plutôt apaisé
les français sont majoritairement
favorables à la pma pour toutes
[Musique]
voilà question simple à vous seriez
députés à l'assemblée nationale vous
votez pour ou contre l'ouverture de la
pma à toutes les femmes
fabienne keller je vote pour après y
avoir beaucoup réfléchi bien sûr et je
voudrais en cet instant me réjouir que
les débats à l'assemblée était apaisée
c'est ma collègue agnès firmin le bodo
qui est agir comme moi deux membres du
même mouvement qui a présidé les débats
et je pense que c'est l'honneur d'un
pays de pouvoir avoir
voilà un débat respectueux de la veine
ou réfléchie vous avez beaucoup hésité
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi j'ai beaucoup
écouté parce que je pense que c'est une
décision importante et j'y suis
favorable
karima delli à moi j'ai su pour parce
que c'est une question de l'égalité des
droits que la france a trop traîné un
seul y avait déjà onze pays européens la
belgique ça existe depuis dix ans donc
il était temps encore de faire ce saut
mais encore faut-il que justement la
société soit comprise et on voit que sur
ces questions sociétales
la société est en avance sur le
politique eva voilà en moins c'est fait
manuellement par bonjour également nos
deux d'un principe d'égalité
c'est une discussion philosophique c'est
toujours ça suscite toujours des
discussions qui sont enflammés dans
notre pays et je trouve ça bien mais je
pense que d'un point de vue conceptuel
il me semble que le droit de la
filiation ce qu'on appelle la filiation
c'est quelque chose de social est pas
quelque chose de biologique et donc à
partir de ce moment là je crois que
c'est une mesure qui va dans le bon sens
je pense qu'elle irait encore plus et
jusqu'au bout dans le bon sens si on
étendait ce droit aussi aux hommes
transsexuels puisque je pense que ça
c'est une proposition qu'on a fait à
l'assemblée nationale qui est
malheureusement a été rejetée il faut
aller au bout pour éviter qu aider des
personnes qui en soit exclue tout en
distinguant bien sûr la pma de la gpa et
moi par ailleurs je suis contre la gpa
par contre et ça ça me paraît important
de le rappeler parce que certains
manifestement veulent semer l'ambiguïté
sur ce sujet dernière question pourquoi
est ce qu'on france dès que l'on touche
à ces sujets sociétaux le mariage pour
tous la fin de vie la pma c'est toujours
houleux alors moi je me suis réjoui que
ce débat sur la pema soit respectueux
pour l'instant j'espère qu'il le sera
jusqu'au bout j'étais sénatrice au
moment du débat sur le mariage pour tous
c'était pas bien c'était vraiment un
moment de d'immenses violences entre
deux partisans comme si quelqu'un des
réseaux et l'autre avaient tort non
c'est des convictions différentes
ce débat trop traîné alors qu'au royaume
uni peu après il ya eu un débat très
respectueux à nouveau mais en une
semaine voilà où chacun donne son avis
après comme en france le comité
d'éthique
donc j'espère que les manifestations qui
sont prévues en france dimanche ne vont
pas réouvrir un clivage la france n'a
pas besoin de clivage elle a besoin de
rapidement et de respect parce que c'est
une question philosophique assez
profonde est que pour la contourner il
faut mettre le débat à la hauteur
nécessaire j'espère que c'est ce qui
sera fait dans les prochaines semaines
vous réjouissiez que ce soit plus
apaisée karima delli baisse est plus
apaisé il faut avancer le 21e siècle
c'est aussi le partage des droits et
l'égalité c'est ça qui nous anime tous
ça doit pas être reculées ces avancées
pour plus de droits
ce sera le mot de la fin c'est la fin de
cette émission merci à vouloir d'avoir
accepté mon invitation est revenue merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis bonne suite
des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]